it was a beautiful early fall day in New
York it was supposed to rain but it
didn't so it's a sign we are told
there's this event you you should come
to that I wasn't sure faculty would drop
everything else they were doing income I
was seeing friends of mine they really
are you walking over with your boss
where are you going an area of the
campus had been roped off for all of us
to go in and here walks in this film
crew and they break out their cameras
it's quite remarkable to see some to a
large number of people whose lives and
activities had been so profoundly
affected by the generosity of one
individual Gerry Len Fest is a great
businessman he was a pioneer in the
cable industry and telecommunications
and Gerry has said that his wealth
should be used for human benefit
Columbia's had a wonderful absolutely
distinguished history we get great
students because we have great faculty
we can't keep great faculty unless we
compensate them well and support them
well we had problems I was trying to
retain a few faculty who were getting
very very generous offers from other
institutions Jameel emphasis had a great
idea
and it's very simple to show the faculty
that they care $25,000 $25,000 a year
for three years the land fest award
helped me or to Paris on a sabbatical
and do research and then bring all of
that into the classroom I was able to
travel to museum collections in Europe
and the Middle East
it gave me additional resources for
childcare and allowed me the time that I
needed to do my research
definitely breathe a connection where
you feel this place values me why would
I go anywhere else when I call somebody
on the faculty it's not always good news
usually when the vice-president calls
you and you are the chair of the
department with something fishy going on
I think my first assumption was he was
probably asking me to serve on some
committee they were completely unable to
reach me because I never answered my
phone
one of the great pleasures of making
these calls is to hear somebody react I
do believe I shrieked and to his ear on
the phone I feel for a moment like I'm a
quiz show host I say look you won the
award Nick said well luckily this time I
have good news for you oftentimes the
faculty to pick up the phone either drop
the phone I had no idea that I was even
up for this award each year there are
award dinners I had the pleasure of
sitting next to Jerry at the awards
dinner and he said to me when he was a
young man he was so influenced by his
teachers that he wanted to give back
Jerry has recognized that teaching is
important because the way in which
faculty truly influenced the future is
through the students they teach teaching
is learning in many ways Aristotle said
that philosophy begins with a sense of
wonder and I think that is exactly what
teaching is about it was one of the
happiest days I've had here at Columbia
I mean I come from
far away I said goodbye to my parents to
my brother and my friends to come here
so it's natural that you react by saying
well you know he was worth it we get
there and there is already a bunch of
people waiting there's a huge camera
crew which was a little bit intimidating
at first end it up because I'm tall
somebody in the back beautiful shorter
lady just put down the phone
several of us were told to stand in the
front and that's how I ended up there I
was standing to the left of the statue
and amanda was right behind me
standing on boxes to make her look ever
so tall I'm only five two and I'm at the
very very top on the right hand side I
look really really tough could everyone
just look this way please while I check
the light thank you Gerry Len Fest has
been one of the most important
supporters of the Earth Institute
he understood the need to have clean
energy for everybody
Gerry has always been there to say yes
Columbia should be advising villages
halfway around the world on how to end
poverty yes this is something important
for Columbia University he really
believes in making solutions but instead
of just talking about those problems
let's put the best minds in one spot and
solve it
Gerry's been incredibly generous to
Columbia Law School we didn't have
enough student housing so Jerry gave the
law school a building called Lynn fest
Hall which is a magnificent space my
professorship would not have existed
without Gerry's contribution had I not
come here we probably wouldn't be
teaching climate change law Jerry has a
very wise vision about legal education
but it's essential to expand the
horizons of our students and to broaden
the curriculum because the world is more
complicated than ever before
the concept of a match is part of
Jerry's basic character that everybody
should give you said look I know the
price of a chair for a professor at
Columbia is three million dollars I'm
going to give you thirty seven and a
half million dollars so all you have to
do is get 25 donors to donate the other
half and they can have a chair in their
name my chair is one of two endowed
chairs in Asian American Studies in the
United States and that's a phenomenal
statement it is an act that does as much
as anyone possibly could to encourage
contributions by others it
a truly selfless generosity to the
University 25 new faculty who expand
exponentially the kinds of things that
were able to teach from sustainable
development to Sanskrit
these support offered to train a
generation of policymakers of scholars
of citizens the Len fest effect is an
effect that goes to every part of the
institution there's a multiplier
generations of students it's an umbrella
trickle-down generations of faculty
there seems to be a land fest presence
almost everywhere every part of the
university has been affected by Jerry
what Jerry has enabled empowered and
helped to get start it reaches around
the world I kept saying you know I'd
like to call this the Lund fest award
and Jerry said no he said this is about
these teachers this is about teaching
this is about the students it's not
about me he said whatever you do don't
use my name I think it's a testimony to
how modest a man Jerry is he does his
work quietly very few people know about
it but an enormous number of people
benefit the same thing with the chairs
twenty-five chairs all of them named
after people who gave the other half
he's somebody who genuinely cares about
his community and feels that he can use
his success to really help those around
him
they made an enormous amount of money
and he wants to give it all away that's
inspirational whenever I say Jerry what
you've done is such a fabulous fabulous
thing he says no no no it's what we've
done it's not what we've done it's what
he's made us able to do I was looking
around to see who else was there and I
was like oh look who's here look who's
here and it was an amazing thing to see
he's touched so many lives through his
contributions standing there on those
steps I'm a part of this collective this
larger group of professors who've in
turn affected me this photo is taking
the power of Jerry's idea and making us
see it this morning on the steps of
Hamilton we had the whole and looking at
the extraordinary people who were there
made one realize this is not just about
identifying individuals this is about
establishing a community the community
that gives to a larger community of
students because they're part of this
Agreement that what we do here at
Columbia will change lives I'm a
beneficiary of the land fest effect
I teach 100 students in the class all of
those students become beneficiaries of
the land fest effect they go out in the
world and do their work and it
multiplies